Today's Show is all about land and how
we cope with the increasing demands of
it not just food but generating energy
space for housing transport even carbon
storage the question is how do we do it
best
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me Tom Heap and yes this week we're
talking all about land as it seems that
our demands on it have exploded
we want it now for so much green energy
yet more and more of us need to eat and
we need more homes and don't forget
leisure
so how is our land used today that
really is the foundation question to
understand everything else well this map
shows you how much is used for each
activity in the UK it doesn't show you
where things happen it shows the amount
of land taken by each activity and their
relative sizes for instance we don't all
live in Wales but the total built up
area is roughly the same size as Wales
not all the poultry is in Northern
Ireland but chickens and turkeys have
that much space you get the idea it also
shows the area taken by potatoes our
beaches broadleaf woods and Conifer
forests even golf courses and Christmas
trees but it is farming that has the
Lion's Share this amount for cereals
things like wheat and barley and then
the rest is for Animals cows both beef
and dairy also grazing sheep in fact 85
percent of the land we use for food is
not directly for us but for rearing
animals or growing their feed now
something that doesn't appear on this
map is solar that's because solar Farms
take up just one thousandth of Britain's
land area tiny in land use but a big
issue especially where one of Europe's
biggest solar Farms is planned Botley
West in Oxfordshire
the size of Heathrow Airport around 2
000 football pitches five and a half
square miles however you measure it this
proposed solar farm will be big but so
is the energy demand we've committed to
removing fossil fuels from our Energy
Mix by by 2035 effectively we need to
build Renewable Power stations both wind
and solar to fill that Gap this land has
a use growing crops like wheat and
barley ready to harvest in about six
months time to feed us or our livestock
so how much food would be lost if it
looked like this
I don't know because I haven't uh I
haven't got those numbers but is that
not important to know that I mean we are
in a world where we need food and we
need energy shouldn't we be balancing
these things I absolutely agree and and
but we do it by land classification so
the land that we are on is not what's
called best and most versatile so it is
not best for food production
oxfordshire's grain Harvest would be cut
by thousands of tons but enough
electricity could be generated for all
of the County's 300 000 homes many local
residents MPS and conservation groups
would prefer the sun's Rays to fall
largely on Plants not panels this whole
area that you can see and for Miles
actually 17 kilometers behind us will be
covered in solar panels it'll be an
ocean of Glass and Metal but the
campaigners insist they're not
anti-green energy it's not the best way
to make renewable energy for this
country there are better Alternatives
which are particularly when it comes to
solar rooftops I mean the the government
is calling for a solar rooftop
Revolution
you could put solar panels on our houses
on on Factory roofs on warehouses none
of this has been done in this area at
the moment why not that recent
Government Review does call for
Accelerated solar rooftop rollout by
scrapping planning requirements but it
also backed solar Farms on poor quality
land it is not either or climate change
is a big problem yeah it certainly it's
massive it's the big problem yes maybe
it is a very big solution yes it does
need a big solution solar is not going
to provide that big solution in this
country solar is helpful but it's not
going to do the heavy lifting that has
to be done by wind power people live
here these are not deserts in China
which is where all the big solar farms
are in the world today
travel Northwest through the Cotswolds
and a new solar farm has taken root the
panels here cover about 18 acres and
deliver 4 500 kilowatt hours that's
around about enough for the nearby town
of charlbury but this place is yielding
more than just electricity they claim it
generates more abundant nature too not
so obvious in January but their
ecologist has measured more abundant
wildlife in the seven years of operation
every year we have generated more
electricity than the predictions it's
adding carbon sequestration because the
land in the first instance has just been
allowed to lie fallow under the panels
we get different more robust grasses
going under the panel and the number of
pollinators the bees the butterflies are
going through the roof the number of
birds has increased dramatically so do
you think this is multi-functional land
doing more than just putting out wattage
yes absolutely
and I think that any solar farm can
think like that in the way that it is
designed there are around 500 further
solar sites already awaiting
construction or approval across the UK
and more in the pipeline
if that land also made space for nature
or occasional sheep it would reduce the
squeeze elsewhere
but making room for nature requires much
more than just tucking it in around
solar panels many argue we should
dedicate more land to Wildlife under new
government subsidy schemes Farms get
more funds for growing Wilderness and
carbon storage less for growing food the
official Net Zero Watchdog the climate
change committee say that we'll need to
use 21 less land for agriculture by 2050
in part by eating a third Less meat
but the thing is Britain already Imports
a lot of food which takes up a lot of
land overseas in fact that's equivalent
to the area of the UK is importing more
food good for our security or The Wider
environment let's ask a farmer what they
think
foreign
and I am a tenant farmer from North
Warwickshire here on our farm we have
beef cattle a flock of breeding use and
we also produce crops for human
consumption I strongly feel that we
should not be putting productive
Farmland into rewilding schemes
[Music]
by rewilding fertile and productive
Farmland we are Outsourcing the problem
whilst I'm all for looking after the
environment and if you have a
unproductive corner of a field that does
you don't get much of a crop off and is
really quite inefficient great pop that
into some sort of stewardship scheme
plantar Wildflower plots but to be
putting big fertile land down with trees
so that and taking it out of food
production is a huge issue if we're
importing the food that we consume and
it's produced at a lower standard than
we can produce here then it is just
brainwashing
[Music]
despite being a livestock farmer I do
personally believe that as a as a
population we do consume too much meat
but I don't think this comes down to
cutting out meat together all of our out
of our diet completely in fact I know
that's not correct because if we weren't
producing livestock here our greenhouse
gas emissions our carbon footprint on
this farm would be so much higher than
it already is
as a farmer I know that the wafer our
industry to become Net Zero and in turn
of our nation is going to be by
integrating more livestock with arable
practices on the farm being able to
graze sheep and livestock on arable land
to reduce the requirements for
artificial input is so important and a
really easy way that we can reduce our
carbon footprint
as Farmers I strongly believe that we
can improve our environment we can
enhance it we can nurture it and look
after it which is what we do here
well with me to talk through the issues
raised by Charlie the farmer is Lydia
colas from the green Alliance they've
just written a big report on the whole
subject of land and climate change Lydia
one of the key points that Charlie the
farmer was making there she is very
worried about taking productive land out
and giving it over to Nature I've got a
point yeah
I think land varies massively across the
country in terms of how productive it is
there are large areas of the country
that aren't actually that well suited to
food so in England 10 of the Farmland
produces just one percent of the overall
food produced across the country so if
we target action for nature and for
climate mitigation at that least
productive Farmland we can actually get
very far without having a huge impact on
food production but we are seeing some
farms in in the lowlands in not just in
perhaps the the less productive
Highlands being taken out and rewilded
that does seem a problem when we're
importing so much food from elsewhere
the when you look at how much land is
dedicated to farming it still is the
majority Farm use more than 70 of the
country is farmed so it's very very
small areas at the moment that are being
taken out for rewilding but climate
change is a massive challenge we know
that we need unprecedented action if
we're going to
avoid the worst effects of climate
change but we won't be helping climate
change if we just shift our food demand
elsewhere and that gets produced in a
climate damaging way I think that is a
major challenge that we face is that our
the way that we are addressing climate
change in this country is most with a
domestic Net Zero strategy and we don't
quantify and take action right now on
our International footprint and I think
that is a huge challenge when this is a
global challenge to address because
we've looked at this map that has you
know the land use in Britain and then
the area that we demand from other
countries in order to to feed us Etc and
we shouldn't be expanding that that
offshore island should we so and there
are things that we could do which would
increase the amount of food that we're
producing in this country and decrease
it overseas like growing not sending
grain to biofuel production which is not
an end use that people aren't eating
that it's going into Vehicles so there
are things that we could do which
increase our food security while we can
still take some of the land out of
production is our Dart our food choices
relevant to this argument definitely
meat production is the most inefficient
use of land for every one calorie that
people eat in beef it's taken 100
calories of grain to produce that so
people at the grains instead obviously
it's a more efficient use of land and we
are seeing that some people are changing
their diets and moving towards
plant-based diets not everyone is going
to do that that's okay what we're also
going to see at the same time are some
forms of processed meat being replaced
by cheaper alternatives which are
absolutely equivalent but that don't
come from an animal one of the big
arguments in land use is whether we
should multi-function land which seems
like a good idea but you've got to be
careful having if you reduce the
efficiency of what you're doing on that
so in effect when it comes to food
should we do it quite intensively where
we do it or when it comes to Industry
should we do it intensively where we do
it rather than mixing the things sparing
versus sharing they call it I think
there is scope to do multiple things on
the land in some cases so land that is
really good for nature like a wetland
can also be really good for climate
change it's a massive carbon sink it's
also a massive store of water so it's
good for flood mitigation so you can get
multifunctional land use off land that
doesn't produce food in some places it
will make sense to focus more on food
production and that land isn't going to
be a carbon sink because if you're
producing lots of food it's just not
possible to also have that lambia carbon
sink so it doesn't make sense to try and
do everything on every bit of land at
Green Alliance we advocate for a three
compartment approach where the land most
suited to food production is focused on
producing food the land that isn't well
suited to food production and on which
it's actually really hard to make a
profit we advocate for focusing that
land on creating habitats for wild
species for storing carbon to mitigate
climate change and then a whole load of
land can be used for both those purposes
and that's really good for many of the
species in this country that depend on
farmland for some of their life cycle
like skylarks and iconic British bird
species
well thanks very much Lydia well after
the break we'll be taking a look at the
golf course that's taking on a new life
as a forest and our Timber buildings the
solution to more sustainable development
of our land
this week we're all about the land under
our feet or maybe under our homes and
buildings let's bring up this map again
to show you the proportion of Britain
that is built upon
despite being quite a densely populated
island the total area taken up by all of
our settlements and roads still equates
to only around the size of Wales but
more housing does demand more land and
greenhouse gas emissions from
construction materials like steel and
concrete are enormous so now many in the
building business are rediscovering the
virtues of Good Old Timber here's Thomas
Moore
Rising six stories above the streets of
East London is a temple to Timber the
new black and white building is
Britain's largest office block
constructed from beams and Columns of
engineered wood the thin layers glued
together at different angles make it
three times stronger than concrete and a
fraction of the weight of Steel and
unlike traditional building materials
that have huge carbon emissions Timber
is sustainable
they're very hard to change these steel
and concrete buildings they're very
static materials we can move around
Timber buildings you can unscrew this
building and you can you know you can
cut holes in it very easily so the
adaptability of these buildings the low
carbon
um qualities of this material and the
fact that we can grow more of it or you
know mean that this is the future of
architecture this is the future of
construction at Cambridge University
they push wood to its limits they've
shown it's structurally possible to
build skyscrapers as tall as 300 meters
from Timber and As Cities grow it could
be a huge part of getting to Net Zero
the production of cement is globally
responsible for something like eight
percent of carbon dioxide emissions and
the construction industry is globally
responsible for about 40 percent of
carbon dioxide emissions so that's a
huge problem it's also a huge
opportunity because it feels like that's
a big number that we can work on to
reduce
switching to Timber could help reduce
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere far
into the future greenstead church is the
oldest wooden building in Europe parts
are a thousand years old
this Timber was sawn from oak trees
growing even longer ago so it's quite
likely it contains carbon that was
sucked out of the atmosphere at the time
of the Vikings and then locked up ever
since
but fear of fire since the grenfell
tragedy makes some experts cautious
about using a combustible material in a
building structure designs need to be
shown to be safe the worst case scenario
for me and you know we can see this um
the combustible cladding issue is if
something goes wrong just once you know
um and we have a significant fire
um I I you know the reaction will be to
ban the materials and then we can't you
know uh we can't derive those benefits
anymore because uh we'll be up against a
huge hurdle but the architect of the
black and white building say the
pushback against Timber has gone too far
carefully used would could construct a
Greener future
Thomas More Sky News in East London now
there are also some chunks of land used
for surprising purposes Leisure or maybe
festive fun here mapped onto Northern
Ireland is a significant chunk just for
Christmas trees and if you look up here
at what's mapped onto the Shetland
Islands we see that all of the UK's golf
courses take up roughly five times the
land used for Orchards but as Skies
Katarina vitotsi has been discovering
it's possible for some of those golf
courses to find a new life
forget tea times it's tree time
this golf course close to Chester has
been taken over by the Woodland trust
who aim to turn 38 hectares of
intensively managed greens Fairways and
bunkers into a re-wilded public space
it's not been used a golf course in
about 2020 and since then it's just been
left as sort of open space historically
this would have been sort of Farmland
many years ago but a lot of these trees
were planted when it was adopted as a
golf course so we've got a little bit of
a head start the ultimate aim is for
this to become part of the Northern
Forest a plan to plant 50 million trees
by 2032 across the north of England
there is a climate and nature emergency
at the moment so anything that we can do
to get more sort of trees into the
landscape is really really important in
this part of Cheshire I think it's about
six percent Woodland cover the national
average is 13
European average is 30 so we really have
got a long way to go over the next few
years the Woodland trust aimed to plan
on 40 000 trees on this site but
re-wilding is also about giving nature
the space and opportunity just to get on
with it itself and that is when you
start to see things like this Acorn
perhaps planted by a bird like a j
that's already become a small oak
sapling
along with grasslands boggy patches and
Wildflower Meadows the re-wildered
course will become a Haven for wildlife
and that not so rare species the dog
walker anywhere where they can have more
public space more community space Green
Space particularly is it's welcome
completely welcome working at home this
morning and then coming out especially
on a day like today is beautiful coming
out like this actually it's just
refreshing it uplifts it's mood
uplifting everything this golf course is
one of several across England set for
rewilding welcomed by campaigners who
say courses take up a disproportionate
amount of green belt but the division
doesn't always need to be so Stark You
could argue as well there is a middle
ground where you know golf courses could
possibly do more in terms of leaving
rough areas more rough for golfers
harder to get out of perhaps to get onto
the greens
um but no but but just creating a more
Mosaic of habitat you know wildfly
Meadows or longer grass and more tree
planting so there are definitely
opportunities and it's getting that
balance right that that's acceptable to
everybody members only know more these
greens offer all
Sky News
now it's time for one of your questions
via the Sky News app Alex Garrett asked
will colder spells of weather become
more Extreme as a result of a warmer
climate well to find out we turn to our
weather producer and meteorologist
Joanna Robinson
cold air at the Arctic and above that in
the stratosphere you've got the polar
vortex now at times the polar ball takes
weekends and as it weakens it allows
Dakota Jet Stream to drift further south
taking the very low temperatures with it
now whilst we're seeing temperatures
rise globally we are seeing an impact in
the stratosphere warming events there to
help weaken the polar vortex
there's other factors to include more
moisture in the atmosphere when we do
have cold events that brings more
snowfall and can lead to further winter
Cooling
as always we want your climate questions
if there's anything that's ever
mystified you about the environment or
whatever you want to get to the bottom
of scan the QR code on your screen right
now and send us your questions which we
will try our best to answer for you and
finally an update on the rare Forest we
visited a few weeks ago the insurance
company Aviva is putting 38 million
pounds into helping to restore Britain's
temperate rainforests the wildlife trust
will use the money to reforest an area
equivalent to 2 600 football pitches
which they think will help store around
000 tons of CO2 every year by 2060.
now before we go just a reminder that
you can catch the daily climate show
weekdays at 3 30 p.m here on Sky News
and you can get all the latest climate
and environmental news on the Sky News
app and website or by scanning the QR
code on your screen right now and that's
it from me this week we'll be back at
the same time next week to talk about
big batteries and polluting plastic bye
for now
[Music]